man he's so
[Music]
confused
britney spears has been using her voice
in the courtroom
and now she is getting back to singing
it's
fun for me over the weekend the 39 year
old performer had some fun in the car
with her boyfriend
sam askari and he shared the sweet
moment
on his insta story
really this is from the beginning
i love this song that's when britt belts
out a verse from her 2001 song
[Music]
lonely
[Music]
yeah she still got it 20 years later
well thank you so much sweetie it's the
first time we've heard britney sing
in years so let's hear that one more
[Music]
time
[Music]
brit's car performance comes amid the
singer's highly publicized ongoing
conservatorship battle
i think it's a very big deal that she's
speaking out and she has told
the court she wants her voice heard
she's come
to a head and she needs to figure out
what she's going to do about this
conservatorship
and she thinks this is the best way to
get her point across
the pop star continues to speak out
against her dad and conservator jamie
spears
and brittany has made it clear she will
keep her career on hold
until her father is removed from the
conservatorship
earlier this month her manager of 25
years larry rudolph
resigned noting that brick quote had
been voicing her intention to officially
retire
over the weekend the 39-year-old singer
also posted a message about her career
to instagram
writing quote look i'm not going to be
performing on any stages anytime soon
with my dad handling what i wear
say do or think
the singer added that she'd rather share
dance videos from her living room
quote i'm not gonna put on heavy makeup
and try try try on stage again
and not be able to do the real deal with
remixes of my songs for years
and begging to put my new music in my
show for my fans
so i quit in the post brit also touches
on her younger sister jamie lynn
who performed a remix of her song till
the world ends during a tribute at the
2017 radio disney music awards
when britney was honored with the icon
award
she wrote in part quote my so-called
support system
hurt me deeply and quite bluntly
continued quote
i don't like that my sister showed up at
an awards show and performed
my songs to remixes then on sunday the
toxic singer
seemingly swiped at her sister again
after
jamie lynn shared this mirror selfie in
a red dress with the caption quote
may the peace of the lord be with you
and your spirit
brit posted this video dancing while
wearing a red top
alongside the caption quote may the lord
wrap your mean ass up in joy today
p.s red
[Music]
after britt posted her message jamie
lynn edited her caption
and turned off the comments maybe i
didn't support the way the public would
like me to
with a hashtag on a public platform but
i can assure you that i've supported my
sister
long before there was a hashtag and i'll
support her long after of course
last month the former nickelodeon star
emotionally addressed her sister's
conservatorship battle on instagram
saying she supports her sister no matter
what
if ending the conservatorship if buying
to mars or whatever the hell else
she wants to do to be happy
i support that 100
because i support my sister i love my
sister always have always will
as long as she's happy
[Music]
you